benvenuti sanità storici oggi al
grandissima richiesta al nuovo episodio
trova gli ingredienti style saltato
l'uomo fare molto
praticamente nello scorso video trova
gli ingredienti drive nascosti dallo
slimer vi avevo detto che se avesse
raggiunto i 20 mila mi piace il prossimo
personaggio sarebbe stato vampiro il
video ha raggiunto tipo 27 mila mi piace
quindi questo personaggio sarà il
bambino il conte dracula
io non l'ho ancora visto paura che i
punti fuori all'improvviso
ovviamente non dovrò farmi prendere
nemmeno per una volta perché se mi
prende anche solo una volta mi trasformo
in vampiro come lui quindi devo stare
super attenta non ho cinque possibilità
come in gres se questo video raggiunge i
30 mila mi piace il prossimo personaggio
sarà il più richiesto in assoluto degli
ultimi mesi e cioè ice cream e il
gelataio cattivo vi ricordate che
abbiamo già fatto il gameplay quindi da
quello mi piace su questo video e ora
andiamo a cercare il papino volevo dire
andiamo a cercare ning li denti slime
non il bambino che voi come sempre
aiutatevi e vedete se trovate qualcosa
di strano in giro ma qualche ingrediente
berlino e qui e spero che mi aiuterà
anche lui è il bambino ma ora andiamo
subito
proviamo in cameretta vedere se c'è
qualcosa
vediamo
merlini inquadrate da sgranocchiando suo
giochino nuovo ok
sembra tutto tranquillo
tutto ok allora iniziamo pure a cercare
gli ingredienti qua non c'è niente non
c'è niente
berlino poi piano guardateli dormendo
non so se sta tornando poco mosse sta
facendo lento quali la vedete
ecco la devo assolutamente prenderla ma
te può fare pienamente per svegliarlo
[Musica]
vediamo se stato argomento
sì mi sembra proprio che stia dormendo
ok sprechiamola piano piano
[Musica]
ce l'abbiamo fatta per un pelo preso la
colla è la colla rossa questa volta
doverlo rifugiarmi qua e non in
cameretta perché quanto pare lui è stato
la cameretta come sua base come suo
rifugio
beh c'è nessuno qua
non lo credo
[Musica]
ma ne fa
ho capito che in questa sala ci dobbiamo
stare superattenti più del normale ma
non so come fare devo devo mettere una
trappola per tirarlo fuori
offriamo ad uscire nuovamente ma penso
che l'unico modo si sa mettere una
trappola
così lui esce dallo studio io posso
prendere gli ingredienti e poi scappò e
torno qua ma che trappola potrei mettere
a cosa piace ai vampiri
oltre al sangue ma non posso ovviamente
prenderlo nave sulla parte però c'è una
cosa che non piace ai vampiri e cioè
l'aglio si apprende dell'aglio magari
riesco ad allontana devoto in cucina o
c'è qualcos'altro che non piace ai
vampiri
c'è un'altra cosa che non piace i
vampiri non ve lo dico
ora vi faccio vedere subito
non posso distrarmi
sostenuti come faccio non posso usare
l'altra arma punto debole dei campini
adesso perché troppo vicino poi meno
devi aiutare una briciola con key cerca
di visto nell'occhio
sì lo so che devo per forza
[Musica]
guardate
sono sicura che li ha messi lì per farmi
una trappola
devo prendermela presto
quella dopo
l'altro punto vengono
tanti
la luce
si distende
ok si banca non solo il bicarbonato di
sodio la soluzione per lei
andiamo se la tenda e ancora aperte c'è
ancora luce lui è bloccato
anzi dopo un po di tempo che i vampiri
stanno alla luce si trasformano in
statue in pietra
così posso fare quello che mio papà ti
amo con la tende chiuse adesso guardate
che cosa quando lui l'ha richiusa
maledizione che faccio
c'è di passi
no io capisco cosa che faccio riapro la
tenda guardate per lenti fantastico che
strappo che l'ha lasciata proprio qua
sopra
chi sono
ma io che ci fai lì sono nel letto di
sopra guardate
perché mi ha messo qui sopra sono
immettere i pupazzi o per fortuna non mi
ha morso ancora non mi sono ancora
trasformata in vampiro anch'io per
fortuna ma chi non sta cercando disabile
qua per venire a salvarmi non merlino si
dice pericoloso no
scendi giù pericoloso berlino che faccio
da può scendere giù da qua sarà il
bambino sta tormento
non c'è qua e allora io scendo bertino
lo so che lui salvarmi ma non puoi da
qua stai puoi farmi da qua
[Musica]
ero accorta che era lì che fast
aggiornamento
[Musica]
non riuscirai a scappare dal mio
castello trasformerò te e merlino di
berlino
[Risate]
[Musica]
marino attacca lo sconfiggi lo vedevo io
non mi faccio sparire
che succede non persone facendo mi sa
che è meglio se scendo piano abbiamo
guardate che cosa è quello è il
carbonato sbaglio allora ho tutti gli
ingredienti non solo dove ho messo la
soluzione per letti proprio a scendere
allora sto scendendo qua
ok preso la scimmia si trasformerà il
vampiro ma io non voglio diventare un
compito perché perché voglio essere una
persona normale vivere di giorno con
d'alema ci sono tanti lati positivi
nell'essere un volitivo lo sai e ad
esempio puoi vivere senza invecchiare
quanti anni tu pensi che io abbia
secondo me te li porti un po male
quindi direi un 32 147.8 l'hai visto non
ci credo sì è vero è una carta
d'identità non ce l'ho l'ho mangiata gli
altri dati positivi di essere un bambino
e chi ti puoi trasformare il pipistrello
non ci piacerebbe volare è soprattutto
di notte
poi anche dormire tantissimo ma non puoi
utilizzare terribile è questo
effettivamente uno degli effetti
collaterali e di via anche per il sangue
delle tre persone e anche questo è un
aspetto molto importante
ap di no mi dispiace ma non accetto la
tua offerta e me ne vado via da grace
non sto scappando no non so faccio solo
a questo effetto si sta coprendo con il
mantello cose non si fanno scappare
sì
addio vampiro ma abbiamo tutto qua dio
sbrigarci sbrighiamoci perché palmare
ok ragazzi abbiamo tutti gli incrementi
ma ci posso credere che sono riuscito a
prendere tutto con la rossa spatola mi
sembra come se manca qualcosa manca
niente
ecco dobbiamo ammettere la corda
bravata
l'accordo ovviamente è rossa con tutta
vada dietro stavolta non rischia di
aprire sete di sangue
prometto che insomma il conte radunano
una certa promesse berlino aiutami
berlino ma che pare dai ormando aiuto di
berlino berlino si sta già trasformando
i pompieri dopo aver associato il suo
sangue
ho scoperto che un carrozzone l'inizio
ancora di riuscire a fare lo slide si
inizia ancora che facendolo sliven
riuscirai a tenerli lontano assenti
perché non mi racconti nella prima volta
che si è dilettato vampiro come sei
diventato vamp io stavo pagando nella
foresta e all'improvviso amministrano di
ronzava sulla testa
mi ronzava talmente tanto che decise di
mangiare a chi ha innalzato bp trento il
call pipistrello effetto e li trasformò
in un bellissimo la masseria erano cost
è diventata solo per potermi avvicinare
mangiante vai non mi trasformo il perché
deciderò all'ultimo momento ce l'abbiamo
bassa favore spiega di diventare un
vampiro berlino perché non si trasforma
il bambino ma sta facendo qualcosa di
strano a mostri stasera quando c'è un
monte ragazzi all'ultimo monetazione
abbiamo volta da stati uniti husain se
volete un altra storia per il vampiro ma
assieme se lo abbiamo fatto anche questa
volta abbiamo vinto
mi raccomando lasciate un bel bps su
questo video e ora vi lascio 4
castellini su cui cliccare per vedere i
miei altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione